>> Okay, so, inspired by 20 questions let's try to write down
exactly what it is that you did in going through your 20
questions to get your answer to discover Michael Jackson was the person
I was thinking about. So, what is the very first thing you did?
>> I tried to imagine a bunch of possible
answers that you could be, could have in mind.
And, I tried to think of a question that
would help separate them into two roughly equal chunks.
>> Okay, so what's the way of putting that in the
language that we've been using for
supervised learning and classification so far?
>> Oh I see. So if I had known in advance, here's here's 200 things that
you might ask me about. And what their,
what their attribute values are. What would be a
question that would split that set in half,
right? So, instead of just imagining a bunch of
things, if I actually had a list, which I do in the case of a training set.
>> Alright,
so the first thing you did is you picked the best
attribute that you could think of. And, by the way, you said
something very particular here. You actually defined what best is. You said,
that best is the same thing as splitting things roughly in half.
So let's revisit that in a moment. Okay, so the
first thing you did is you picked the best atribute. You
asked a question about it and then, depending upon the answer,
you went and picked another attribute right? Does that seem fair
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
So, we think about decision trees, a way of talking about that is that
you follow the path of the answer, and then lather, rinse and repeat. [LAUGH].
You went back and pick the best attribute, asked the question, followed the
answer path, so on, and so on, and you kept doing that until what?
>> Until, I narrowed the space of possibilities to,
in this case, just one item.
>> Right, so until you got to the answer. All right.
And that is an algorithm. So you pick the best attribute,
and you actually define what best attribute was. You want to
pick one that would somehow eliminate at least half of the
things which you might worry about and keep the other half
in play. You asked a specific question. You followed the path
to that and then you went back and you picked another
attribute and so on and so forth until you got an answer
that you wanted to. That's an algorithm and that's an
algorithm that we might use to actually build a decision tree.
And the only difference between what you did and what you
would do with learning a decision a tree is that, since
you don't know in advance what the answer actually is going
to be, because you don't know what specific object I might
be thinking of, you have to actually follow all possible paths
at each time and think of all possible best next attributes
until you completely can answer any question. Does that make sense?
>> I see. So, right, so instead of
just playing the game interactively, I kind of
imagine all possible ways it could go and
build that whole flow chart, that whole tree.
>> Right, so, let's see if we can do that with some pictures
and I actually want to decide rather I really believe your definition of best.
Okay?
>> Sure.
>> Alright, so, let's do that.